Viewer discretion is advised.
In part one we learned what the hfs in
principle is and how social taboos
affect the profanity of a society.
Now I want to dive into American taboos
and explore how are taboos have changed
over time and how profanity has
followed.
Because profanity has drastically
changed with slurs and words about group
identity quickly becoming the worst
kinds of profanity of this generation.
And we're going to trace this change and
profanity through the lives of
Comedians,
people who challenged taboos for a
living.
And our story begins in 1961 when lenny
bruce is arrested for saying cock sucker
on stage.
Now that name may fly over some modern
heads,
but at the time Lenny Bruce was the
biggest thing in comedy in rolling
Stone's best standups of all time.
Bruce is number three on that list and
if comedy loves being on the edge,
then lenny was the guy dancing off
cliffs.
His comedy took on every American sacred
cow from race to sexual puritanism and
he would say anything,
even if it got him arrested and his
whole life was full of legal issues.
He was in and out of court houses for
saying the wrong words,
appealing and just dealing with a cold
legal system and obscenity laws.
All the while he was whittling away
eventually dying in his home in 1966
four years before New York's Highest
Appellate Court would vindicate him of
all charges.
One of his prosecutors later said,
we all knew what we were doing.
We use the law to kill him.
And this is a pivotal moment because
even though America is prosecuting
comics for breaking taboos,
there was also a shift taking place in
young people right around the 60s and
seventies America has the sexual
revolution and the civil rights movement
that totally shake up the value system
of America and change the taboos.
So 10 years after bruce gets arrested,
another comedian,
George Carlin is coming up,
similar style,
similar anti authoritarian and a similar
fascination with bad words and pushing
the edge.
But this time the culture has changed,
so when Carlin performed seven words,
you can't say on television,
which is loaded with the worst profanity
of the day,
it's a huge success.
You know what I mean?
It's just like we've decided there'd be
somewhere as we won't say all the time
and I was just trying to find out which
words they were for sure.
All of them I wanted to list and I
wanted to know the ones that she could
never say on television.
I mean the filthy words that are always
filthy and all I could think of was
shit,
Piss,
fuck cock cock sucker motherfucker.
He was just as provocative as lenny
bruce was except time had gone by and
the taboos of the older generation were
weakened.
The difference between Carlin and Bruce
was when they did the act.
Carlin mentions this idea in an
interview.
Lenny and I had this language in common
and he brought,
he was the first one to make language an
issue and he suffered for it.
I was the first one to make a language
issue and to succeed from it.
Lesson from George Carlin is obvious in
profanity and in comedy.
Timing is everything.
But this cultural shift that Carlin
built a career on didn't stop there.
Hfs words have continued to weaken and
as good as Carlin's bit was almost 50
years later,
his list of dirty words you can't say on
television needs an update because on tv
and especially on the Internet,
you can say any of those words that you
want.
Now don't be turned this back around
when we stopped being a con,
that was bob.
Bob had bits,
tips give,
give him me to fucking creeps.
You know that Dexter Lt,
this is a waste about damn time.
You pissed me off.
San Francisco Cox,
I can.
This is called cop took up shit on shit.
Shit.
Judge,
judge,
judge.
So to recap what Lenny Bruce got
arrested for is what Carlin got
celebrated for and now you can win
Carlin's bad word Bingo.
Just flipping through a few channels.
These words are hardly taboo or
forbidden at all anymore.
In fact,
a study came out that just over five
years across all TV networks,
the usage of traditional profanity went
up 69% and over 50 years,
authors were 28 times more likely to
include traditional swearing in the
books they wrote.
So there's clear empirical evidence that
hfs words have been normalized.
Not that they're completely harmless,
but they've been robbed of most of their
bike.
Hfs words in America are something like
the queen of England.
There's still the face of profanity,
but there's not much power behind them.
But while hfs words were being declawed,
a special class of words became even
more toxic and unsayable then before
slurs,
the inwards hate speech,
microaggressions,
anything targeting identity,
these became the new sacred cow to
replace the old.
You won't get fired for saying fucking
the office,
but you might get fired for saying the
other f word.
Now it's worth taking a moment to say
that slurs are different from other
types of profanity.
After all,
they specially target groups,
unlike other bad words,
acids,
universal,
because everyone has one,
but not everyone is a homosexual.
So words like Faggot seem much more
targeted,
so perhaps slurs do deserve a special
place in our language.
That said,
there's something about this profanity
that I don't like.
Often we judge the word by itself
condemning syllables regardless of
situation.
Chris Rock noted this in an interview
saying why he stopped performing at
colleges,
because quote,
they're way too conservative,
not in their political views,
but in their social views and in their
willingness not to offend anybody.
You can't even be offensive on your way
to being inoffensive.
In other words,
even if you have something wholesome to
say,
you better not use the no,
no language on your way to making that
point.
He goes on to mention someone else who
also hated the new profanity.
I remember talking to George Carlin
before he died and him saying the exact
same thing.
In fact,
he has a bit about it.
Visit different group to get pissed off
at you in this country for everything
you're not suppose to say.
Can't say fruit.
Can't say faggot.
Can't say queer.
Can't say Nancy boy.
Can't say pansy.
Can't say nigger.
Boogie Jake Jigaboo skinhead jungle
bunny.
Morely more than Yana Schweitzer.
There is absolutely nothing wrong with
any of those words in and of themselves.
It's the intention behind the words that
makes them good or bad.
I get tired of people talking about bad
words and bad language bullshit.
It's the context that makes them good or
bad,
but despite that eloquent argument for
the total liberation of words,
I can't help but think that Carlin lost
his war for total free speech,
even if he won his battle for liberating
a type of profanity because profanity is
a human universal,
deeply rooted in societal taboos and
though these taboos can shift with time,
they never disappear entirely,
so the profanity won't either.
It will only change.
This has been the story in America in
the last 50 years.
We have shifted from primarily in hfs
culture to primarily and in cultural
swearing.
For me,
this suggests that we don't get less
sensitive as much as we change what
we're sensitive about and this is
ultimately brought forward.
A few questions in my mind.
What balance of free speech and
sensitivity towards social issues do we
want given that taboos change over time?
How can we recognize that word's harm?
People without capitulating towards an
ideology that condemns words outside of
their context.
And finally,
is it inevitable that our kids will
simultaneously think we were being
prudes and bigots?
Only time will tell,
Aye.
I wish I had the worst.
So express this and that's been his
thing.
And then my chest and stomach is flatter
him.
When I hear your name,
all those vibrations to hedge rums,
I'm making some soup and I love the cute
things that we do watching me write my
lyrics and you critique them.
And so that's something you never have
to put your energy into.
Your said what an answer is something
that Jay,
thank you for watching that video.
Number one.
If you like that music,
go checkout Sinica be and joy Pecoraro.
Number two,
you liked the video.
Go discuss it in the comments below.
Or go join us on discord.
Reddit,
twitter,
you know,
follow me anywhere and we'll see you
next week with another video.
Thanks.
Oh,
no doubt about it.